on va poursuivre sur cette crise à
l'aéroport de Montréal entre autres mais
dans d'autres aéroports aussi avec nous
mes rendez-vous directeur de
l'Observatoire international
d'aéronautique et de l'aviation civile
de l'UQAM merci beaucoup d'être l'homme
monsieur Ibrahimi on se demande comment
on peut expliquer un tel chaos on évoque
la pénurie de main d'oeuvre est-ce que
le pénurie de manoeuvre va le dos trop
large ou c'est vraiment ça le problème
principal c'est vrai que joue un rôle
important aujourd'hui mais le fait de
tout mettre sur le dos de peignoir ça ne
marche pas on aurait pu le prévoir
pendant la crise pendant la pandémie
c'est vrai que pendant deux ans
l'industrie de l'aviation c'est un des
secteurs qui a été le plus touché
parfait mais il fallait prévoir qu'il y
aura une après crise aussi une
appréhendé mieux aussi mais au Canada on
a tout planifié comme si les variables
de La cri de la pandémie vont durer
éternellement et on n'a pas prévu par
exemple en termes de maintien de domaine
des expertises qui étaient déjà sur
place qui sont Konami à pied qui sont
allés trouver du travail on aurait pu
mettre des des programmes en place pour
essayer de les maintenir ce que nous
n'avons pas fait le gros neuf fédéral a
toujours été vraiment très réact très
j'allais dire laxiste et à chaque fois
qu'ils ont été au pied du mur là où
c'est devenu un scandale sur la place
publique sur les réseaux sociaux là ils
ont commencé à réagir il faut quand même
le dire que le ministre de transport
c'est le 15 juin qu'il a annoncé qu'il
allait engager plus de douaniers alors
c'est quand même il fallait le faire 15
juin 2021 pour aujourd'hui pas 2022 mais
on se demande s'il y a pas aussi des
problèmes logistiques de la part des
transporteurs lorsqu'on voit des vols à
nuls retarder une fois deux fois trois
fois les gens qui doivent dormir par
terre à l'aéroport si on sait que il y a
peu de vol ou que la moitié des vols
finiront par respecter leur horaire
pourquoi on ne les prévoit pas au bon
moment ou pourquoi on en prévoit pas
moins pour éviter d'avoir en annuler
passer justement un petit peu la
solution que Monsieur Dramé l'ami sur la
table aujourd'hui disons que la capacité
de l'aéroport à fournir des services
l'ensemble des vols qui arrivent et les
vols qui partent
on n'est plus capable de fournir alors
peut-être il va falloir équilibrer un
petit peu baisser la pression et
peut-être pour ça donc réduire le nombre
de vols mais il faut savoir aussi que
les compagnies pleines planifient comme
ils sont vraiment à la au maximum de
leurs capacités en tête de personnel
c'est que il suffit juste par exemple
que quelques minutes ou quelques heures
avant un vol un pilote soit testé
positif à covid ou quelque donc à ce
moment-là ce pilote ne pourra pas
prendre son vol et on est tellement
surcapacité d'utilisation des ressources
qu'on n'a pas de pilotes de réserve
comme on avait avant on peut pas
retourner avec des bonbons tu prends le
vol donc cette capacité là pour à cause
de pénurie de pilote aussi donc on peut
pas le faire donc ce qui fait que les
vols sont annulés à la dernière c'est
pas vraiment pas la mauvaise volonté de
compagnies aériences c'est vraiment on
est dans une situation où la pénurie de
main d'oeuvre et cette espèce de retour
un peu chaotique à cause des problèmes
mais la situation tel qu'on la voit en
ce moment lorsqu'on voit les piles de
valise qui sentent qui s'entassent
lorsqu'on voit des gens coincés à
l'aéroport pendant un long moment ça
peut d'une part nuire à la réputation
des transporteurs aériens et est-ce que
ça peut aller jusqu'à diminuer l'envie
de voyager des gens qui avaient des
projets regardez je voyais un petit peu
sur le site un peu spécialisé sur les
plateformes et tout ça des gens qui
arrivent et qui commence à raconter
leurs expériences d'arriver à Montréal
franchement ça fait pas une très belle
image de Montréal et pourtant nous
sommes une ville très très attrayante
nous avons des sites touristiques
extraordinaires nous avons des
compagnies aériennes de très bonne
qualité nous avons un aéroport des
aéroports de très bonne qualité sauf que
c'est ces messages là sur les réseaux
sociaux ces messages là donc sur le site
spécialisé font en sorte que bon ben
Montréal passe pour une ville infernale
ou c'est pas la peine d'y aller donc
c'est franchement c'est même exagéré
parce que une fois que vous avez franchi
la porte de l'aéroport bon bah je dirais
pratiquement tout le reste est normal et
vous on a accès à tout ça mais et il y
en aussi même commence à même des
spécialistes de touristes qui commencent
à dire n'allez pas à Montréal n'allez
pas au Québec n'allez pas au Canada et
ça c'est dommage mais en même temps
monsieur Ibrahimi on nous répète la
situation et la même partout dans le
monde on fait face aux mêmes enjeux
est-ce que c'est le chaos autant
lorsqu'on se dirige vers d'autres pays
ecoutez au début de mois de juin on
citait l'aéroport de Nice comme un des
endroits puis en France j'ai été
mercredi dernier à partir du moment où
je suis sorti dans l'avion et j'ai
quittais l'aéroport pour prendre un taxi
ça a pris 14 minutes d'accord alors donc
c'est c'est pas alors je dis pas qu'il y
a pas de problème il y en a des
problèmes on cherche des solutions on
trouve par exemple les Allemands vont
faire venir des des experts étrangers
pour une courte période pour faire face
à cette pénurie de demain ça c'est par
exemple à Paris oui il y a un problème
mais c'est une grève des employés donc
c'est la même chose mais c'est les
grèves des employés donc ce qui fait que
la nature de problèmes n'est pas le même
donc dans l'orgueil la solution est plus
à la portée de la main que non
malheureusement puisqu'on doit aller
puiser dans un bassin de main d'oeuvre
qui est très très dans nos jours
Ibrahimi pour les voyageurs pour les
transporteurs et même pour l'économie en
général on va ressentir les contreplus
de ça
sur le nombre de réservations on pensait
que le secteur de l'aviation allait
reprendre et malheureusement ça ça vient
un petit peu si vous voulez réduire
restreindre cette capacité de reprise et
deuxièmement il faut quand même pas
oublier que l'aviation de façon générale
un secteur structurant dans notre
économie c'est-à-dire que
ça contribution en termes de création de
richesse est très important alors quand
là sont freinés pour des questions de
logistiques malheureusement ça ça a un
impact sur l'ensemble de la société et
entre-temps beaucoup de voyageurs
mécontents merci beaucoup d'avoir été
l'homme monsieur Brahim c'est toujours
un plaisir pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]